foreign
[Music]
a new show from The Spectator in which
we take a different look at a big story
in the news
this week our first week we'll be
looking at the Qatar World Cup which is
a subject on everybody's Minds as
England are about to play Iran as we
start this recording
uh I'm joined by Sam Leith our literary
editor and William cook a frequent
contributor to The Spectator who also
writes for the independent and the Aldi
William I'll start with you because you
had this terrific piece in uh on the
spectator's website over the weekend
um about the what the legacy of the
Guitar World Cup might be and you made
this very interesting point that um the
reason British people one of the reasons
British people get so uh cross and angry
about the Qatar World Cup is because we
feel a particular pain when we look at
uh this huge corporate enormous Global
sporting event and how different it has
become now to what we think of football
the game we created what we think
football's meant to be about yeah
absolutely I mean that's something I was
thinking about in my my kind of memories
of
of watching football as a kid you know
this you know and I realized how much
it's changed and how much it's moved
away from that uh thing of standing on
The Terraces what we call kind of
terrorist culture I suppose and all
those things that that entails and I
guess it's inevitable result of
globalization you know I mean uh the
first International was England Scotland
150 years ago in Glasgow
um no problems there uh then FIFA's
founded in 1904 England joins belatedly
in 1905 leaves again
and then joins again
um has a bit of a kind of brexit in-out
sort of moment and but right from the
start I think there was a dichotomy you
know between
England Britain being the creators of
this game
and then you know FIFA turning it into a
global game eventually I mean
interestingly it started off with I
think the eight founder members in 1904
were all
European Continental countries so no
problems there to start with but of
course the broader it gets the more
problems you run into and I think this
world cup is kind of like the
apotheosis of that really well is that
the so all the outrage and the disgust
it's really you know obviously there are
issues at State gay rights migrant
workers but the real tools of the
discussed for a lot of people is just
that it's become so obviously all about
money and that's what this world cup is
and that's how Qatar got the World Cup
yeah and and and I think the more Global
it gets the more International it gets
well the more costly it gets and the
more of an incentive there is to give it
to somebody who's going to pay the most
I guess that's that's that's pretty much
it I think and I'm you know we we had
little bits of of this sort of disquiet
in the past I mean the first thing I'd
say is this Sports washing thing is not
new 1934 the second World Cup there was
Mussolini was in power in Italy and he
used that pretty effectively to kind of
put his thing across so so you know
already sport was under the cost a
little bit then and then we had
Argentina in 1978 which I loved as a kid
I mean it was just glorious and
wonderful and uh and and it's only kind
of belatedly that you read up about all
the things that were going on and you
know the Disappeared people some of them
who could actually hear the games going
on from the places they were
incarcerated in and stuff and you think
oh my gosh I had no idea at the time but
this time around we we kind of do know
at the time and I think that makes a
difference ignorance was Bliss it isn't
anymore well somebody let me put this to
you Sports washing the argument for it
is that the country that the the
autocracy that hosts the World Cup it's
by opening itself up to the world uh it
liberalizes and it changes is that
that's the constructive engagement
argument I think
I think it's a very questionable one
um I mean actually in terms of the
spotlight that has swung onto Qatar this
time around I think it hasn't been quite
what what they wanted you know it's it's
been that the whole world has been
talking about qatar's crappy human
rights record yes
um and indeed they have done labor
reforms yeah I mean I think as a result
amnesty as I understand it says that the
daily reforms have been then you know
yeah pretty notional so far
um and you know there is obviously the
point that in building all the
infrastructure for the World Cup
you know migrant neighbors were more
than usually under the Cosh and you know
there's still an uncertified number of
deaths have resulted so there is a kind
of some Direct
actual harm in the world that seems to
have resulted directly from the World
Cup going to Qatar
um I mean I think
yes of course it swings the spotlight
and that
does open things up there is an extent
to which constructive engagement works
but I think
these countries these autocracies
wouldn't be interested in hosting these
events in the first place if they didn't
think that the balance of value to them
PR wise and sports watching wise and I
guess
financially was the other way I mean I I
think it's highly unlikely that you know
all these I mean take for example you
know the the Olympics in China
you know there was a whole thing it was
even suggested plausibly I think that
she went to
Putin said look don't invade Ukraine for
a bit because we're really enjoying them
yeah you know we're enjoying the
attention and Prestige that the workers
China and I don't think
you know the Qatari royal family decided
to hold the World Cup there simply
because they wanted to do a service to
the small number of Qatari football fans
do you think I'm not suggesting that you
do have any uh connections with the
royal family there but do you think they
regret
uh being awarded This World Cup do you
think it's turned out to be a painful
experience for them I I expect so
um I mean I
you know there's that sort of lovely
description of all those
um you know off the guitar team was
taking such a dunking yes um yesterday
at the time recording
um in their first match apparently all
these sort of Lamborghinis were kind of
pulling out of the car park at half time
and kind of driven by little dark clouds
over the heads of the drivers um so I
think it has sort of backfired to an
extent in terms of world PR but as I say
I don't think they would have
done it in the first place yes you know
all those bribes must have been for a
reason there's a lot of talk as always
about Western hypocrisy uh there's no
William and I think
um when it comes to this subject I think
some of it is is correct uh I mean you
know as you put in your piece football
is talking about black lives matter
um and then actually going and playing
in this world cup do you think uh all
the boycott talks should have been taken
more seriously well I never think sports
players should boycott sports events
because the wonderful thing about sport
is in that on that pitch in football or
in the Athletics track or whatever it is
that is a kind of pure space isn't it
it's a space that's removed from the
real world and that's why it's magical
to us it's a kind of parallel universe
in a way you know where where this
different
activity is playing out that has no
connection with us and our real lives
and that's why people escape on a
Saturday afternoon when they go and see
football it takes them away from
everything else
and I guess the big question here is can
we kind of hermetically seal that
environment can can you just make the
pitch a pure straight argument to those
no I mean you know as you've said since
the 30s Sports washing has been a thing
I mean the space in which sport is
played is as you say it's an abstract
hermetic rule-bound
sort of you know unworldly thing but all
of the stuff that surrounds it is
profoundly political and profoundly to
do with money and commerce and power and
it seems to me
you know the the big lie has always been
as supporters above politics because
it's definitely possible well I mean
let's carry on with the constructive
engagement stuff through a bit because
you know I mean this is the first World
Cup held in the Muslim world uh
presumably we all want a better
engagement better relations with the
Islamic world this is a great
opportunity in many ways for you know
western eastern Islam and secularism to
come together and in this in some event
but of course it's massively
overshadowed by by the politics and by
the routes do you not think that we're
perhaps in our desire to show that we
disapprove of the qataris very much we
are sort of thumbing our noses at
something possibly greater
um
I don't really know I mean it seems to
me that
you know unless we are I mean you know
as you say this idea about weapon
hypocrisy does have some purchase
um I mean I think Robert Toombs argued
plausibly that you can't simultaneously
you know be sort of anti-colonial and in
favor of exporting your values but at
the same time
you know we can and do make moral
judgments and Export our moral judgments
in the world and you know unless you're
an absolute moral relativist
you will take a view that you know and
we see in all sorts of spheres huge
amounts of blood and treasure are spent
effectively on exporting more reviews if
that more of you might be it's not okay
for a country to invade its neighbor
or
you know it's not okay to have
um you know a regime committing genocide
which you know there's a whole set of
what we essentially agree are more
universals and I think it's
we shouldn't get into a kind of cultural
cringe where making any sort of moral
judgment or asserting any sort of
universal value is somehow wrong or
imperialist or yes and yet the I don't
think the Sportsman should carry the can
because they are doing something
different ideally hopefully and I'm very
uncomfortable when when Sports
professionals do start to engage with
political positions even ones that I
agree with because I I think they're
kind of they're kind of breaking down
that that that's what can they pick and
choose though I mean I think one of
probably one of the strongest
distinctions that's been made here at
centimeters that's probably a reason why
it's like Qatar is a Sovereign Nation it
can make its own rules it's not
necessarily up to Western powers to
dictate in a kind of liberal imperialist
way what Qatar doesn't its borders but
at the same time it's the organizations
like FIFA and footballers who spend a
lot of time
spouting on moral issues and making a
sort of great show of liberal
universalism who when it comes down to
it
they follow the money I absolutely and
you have to yeah you know you have to
pick and choose a little bit I think
nobody's doing the defensive FIFA take
at the moment yes I think there is a
well Crazy Cakes and his um Infantino
Infantino yeah well that was a
ridiculous speech wasn't it but I think
it's I mean even though it was also that
which again I thought was was where the
Western hypoxia argument
seems to me to have to stop is that him
saying well the West
has been you know morally compromised
for thousands of years so they need to
get their house in order before they
criticize slavery here and now I'm like
saying you know you may be the indirect
beneficiary of your ancestors
involvement in slavery you now think
slavery is wrong
um but you shouldn't criticize it when
it's happening here now and in the world
um it seems to me just absolute nonsense
I'll I'll be talking a little way about
a practical problem here with the World
Cup as it stands as this Festival where
all the
different football teams are kind of
camped there for six weeks or whatever
however long it is I mean when I was a
kid I remember we used to follow games
on the Telly or whatever that were
happening behind the Iron Curtain when
you know Western East were braced for
the next nuclear war that wasn't a
problem because the teams flew in they
played the game and they flew out the
same night they were they were there and
back in 24 hours and clearly for
everybody watching and it wasn't a
problem if somebody was presenting on
Sports night or whatever because you
know the team flew in they got to the
stage and they played the match they
went home again it seems to me that the
kind of problem is this this sort of
feeling of a Fiesta of a of a festival
of uh of a wonderful coming together I
mean ironically in this day and age it
would be perfectly possible for the
England team to fly in and out for each
match well is that is that where the the
problem of huge corporate involvement
gets big gets Messier because
corporations now are very keen on
projecting values you know you know
every major corporate sponsor of an
event like World Cup will have a kind of
gay rights messaging agenda and then you
can't blend that when you're having a
World Cup in in a place like Qatar you
can't have those two things at the same
time well absolutely and I mean this is
why it was very interesting going to
that FIFA Museum in Zurich because you
kind of look into the history you think
a bunch of guys get together they love
football they want to play football
wouldn't it be fun to have games between
different countries that would be great
wouldn't it so eight of them get
together and they're like Switzerland
Denmark you know France Italy whatever
Spain no problem obviously then the
politics intervenes in the 30s and gets
scuppered very early on but ultimately
if FIFA's goal is to make it a global
game in the end the values as you say of
the kind of Founders where there still
is this sort of Continental Social
Democratic sensibility is going to come
up against the reality of places where
they love football but don't don't love
the the touchy-feely notion so the
people who started the whole thing don't
you think it's just it's quite unfair to
expect a sportsman to have to uh stand
up for values absolutely the Sportsman I
mean and and I mean this this goes into
all sorts of things and and actually
things that I like and that I approve of
I mean even kind of when Pop piece on
your shirts and things like that I mean
I feel the only way forward with this I
mean you know this is going to carry on
I mean we had it in Russia before eight
years ago four years after Putin invades
uh Crimea I mean this is this is not
going to stop with Qatar I think it's
just focused everybody's mind because
it's just such a pure sort of example of
it that we can all kind of get our heads
around it but it's been going on it's
yeah it's the sort of weirdest example
in some ways but Sam isn't the problem
you know and you might accuse me of what
a boundary here but it's the massive
inconsistencies in that England's about
to play Pakistan uh at Cricket I think
we're about to go on a tour of Pakistan
homosexuality is illegal prison
sentences for for um homosexual acts in
Pakistan we're not going to see the same
kind of uh grandstanding about that
Saudi Arabia and we played Iran and the
you know I mean are playing Iran I think
as we as we speak in yeah very shortly
yeah but now I
yes you're absolutely right there is
you know in the world as it is there's
endless engagement with you know in
countries trade with countries whose
values they don't share this you know we
all wander around with phones in our
pocket containing precious metals that
have been you know almost always
produced in
um you know extremely unethical and
unsavory conditions
you know I think we all
do engage in you know various forms of
hypocrisy yes but I think it's
impossible to make the per you know it's
possible to make the perfect the enemy
the good and it seems to me Qatar is a
particularly Stark
and if you like useful
you know demonstration of a point where
these these there is this grinding of
Gears with values where and I think it
certainly hasn't helped the you know
grotesque corruption
um with that seems to have
brought about this situation in the
first place and that kind of sense in
which um
you know here is a country being awarded
the football World Cup when it's
basically got no interest in football no
infrastructure for football and a
climate that makes playing football at
the usual time of the World Cup
completely impossible so it simply
becomes the Bellwether you know it
becomes a beacon of this and I think
you know what what a battery
you know has some
legitimacy it's not Merit
um but but you can what about yourself
into a position of complete morals
supineless and I don't think that's the
right thing to do I mean I think the
interesting thing here is that it's like
pretty touched on with this it's the
invasion of money into the game that
creates all these problems I mean could
England fly in and fly out for each game
well not if there's all sorts of
corporate stuff going on that they're
kind of signed up to or have to
participate in or whatever and I mean
this is something that's changed
enormously in our lifetimes I mean it's
extraordinary to me I mean I I my wife
grew up in um Southport where a lot of
the Liverpool players used to live uh in
the 70s and 80s when they're European
Champions and her dad worked in local
government and these players were living
in the same street we we used to see
Kenny dalglish mowing his lawn now I
don't know if any Premier League
football is hopefully they do but I mean
it was still it shows how much things
have changed you know and and it's the
money it's the money that blows this
thing up it's also kind of because it's
it's become so much to do with public
relations isn't it which is part of the
money thing The Branding the peel and
it's you know maybe the point about is
is the sort of jujitsu thing going on
that as much as the visibility of the
World Cup you know makes it makes it
possible to hold up the hypocrisy the
brands it makes it possible to draw
attention to garage human rights record
in a in that way and I mean even though
you know I don't think it's in anything
like a kind of human right to drink beer
while you watch football I sort of would
just love to know what discussions are
currently going on between FIFA and
Budweiser yeah
well actually let's talk a bit about PR
because that was what I wanted to end on
is that it's well known that all the
Gulf States spend huge amounts of money
on PR often employing very expensive
london-based uh PR operations
um and you know you had the Saudi Arabia
have recently sort of bought the world
of golf or they're threatening to take
over the world of golf and they faced
huge PR backlash against it
ditto a lot of people say that the pr
drive against Qatar is all funded by the
UAE and possibly Israel so do you have
the situation where you have a lot of
journalists who are um as we know
underpaid and unable to kind of just get
their mitts around the subject properly
and being led by the nose uh by PR
people and sort of you know thinking oh
well you have to sound morally outraged
by this and that's a good story
um to help get some traffic or whatever
but it's actually all PR people pulling
the strings behind the scenes well I
think I think there's a lot of Truth in
what you say I mean I think uh
inevitably if you ever accept any
Hospitality somewhere you know it's it's
not quite the same and I've accepted
hospitality and Qatar and I found it a
fascinating place I mean I think the
difference is is sport is something that
has this kind of Purity and then when
that Purity is then kind of Taken and
sort of applied to the whole event or
the whole regime or whatever that's when
it makes things uncomfortable I mean
I think sport is different and I wish
and and I share Sam's uh apprehension
about the kind of impossibility of doing
this but but I wish we could build a a
stronger wall between the event on the
pitch and all the other nonsense
happening around it and and the players
need protecting because these days with
social media with stuff going all around
around the world in an instant they're
in the spotlight more than ever I mean
this stuff has happened before the
England players in the 30s when they
played in Germany were told to do a Nazi
salute and they were terribly
compromised by that they all ended up
doing it and they're all in a photo
together and it's rotten for them you
know it was rotten for them but that was
a photo
now these players are really they they
need everybody else's help basically I
mean okay they get paid a lot of money
or whatever but they're still under a
lot of pressure they're trying to do
something else they should be left to do
that thing and and it should mean that
there's nothing that goes on to the
pitch or the side of the pitch or
whatever and and actually the the
sponsors need to retreat a bit as well
well I mean that lastly I mean isn't
that inevitably going to happen as the
World Cup progresses and particularly if
in England if england do particularly
well if Wales do particularly well let's
say I mean don't think a lot of these
concerns inevitably vanish rightly or
wrongly
what you mean is that's what we'll be
excited because everyone was if england
has a chance of winning the World Cup
we're not going to be talking about
human rights in Qatar
well I'd like to thank some old moaning
minis like myself will carry on you'll
carry on good for you
well I think we'll uh wrap it up there
but uh the game is about to start
actually so we can um go and watch it
and carry on uh morally grandstanding
about everything as we do thank you very
much for watching the view from 22 do
tune in next time
foreign
[Music]